[Music]
Hornung you j/k booze a university
professor spent a hundred and ninety
five thousand dollars of federal grant
money on strip clubs oh no he was
researching he was too horny cuz a girl
that really loved him Joe doing it to
pay for their medical degree oh I
thought he was uh like a sexologist he
wanted to save these women oh they're
just doing it to put themselves through
college I thought he was a researcher
shaking the grant and reassigning it
he's a professor of Drexel University oh
my lord what happened you went to school
dude
Jeff is her manager Jeff is my manager
sorry old separate videos yeah they come
out randomly same Oh his name is uh dr.
chica
no Walker pot no what the Wow
you know dr. Tony the bow-wow no bump
koala dr. Kowal oh yeah he's the head of
the electrical and computer engineering
department he has been the head for 27
years see if he was a professor
wrecked-tile dysfunction i would have
been like oh that makes sense he's just
going there to make sure that his pills
are working yeah whatever
yeah normal yeah no so he got Courtney
if you got these grants from the Navy
the Department of Energy and the
National Science Foundation and they
have found that this fixed 56 year old
has miss appropriate funds mr.
procreated fun this whole time so
misappropriation or is it recent
redistribution redistribution that's
true cuz when you get financial aid you
could use it on whatever you want but it
wasn't meant for him it was for research
oh yeah it was meant for him to research
into his department should have been a
sexologist what he gave it to single
moms instead and I think there's
something nice single moms trying to put
themselves through Community College and
she is a Robin Hood of the present day
that's why this man is a hero cake from
the [ __ ] academics yeah give to the
single mom I wouldn't
with Mercedes okay fine I'll give it to
him if he wasn't hard at all the whole
time yeah we repeat the whole time yeah
I think it was rock hard the whole time
oh then he doesn't deserve it why can't
he do good deeds and get hard well
sometimes when I do charity I get a
little bit hard oh god don't ever
volunteer for Toys for Tots well that's
not the one that's not the one
nah it's soup kitchens Oh only because
they need me so much cockroach you smell
it just gets you going
yikes okay so the university discovered
the [ __ ] poor this way to hide his
motor oh okay
let's go on now I can't I'm done okay so
that's the university discovered this
fraud in 2017 during an internal audit
and they alerted the government because
he was treating his friends and
colleagues to lap dances using the
school's money yeah the university did
an interim review my ass the university
was at the strip club and they like wait
the fuck'em in it and they saw him there
yeah oh and then it's been 20 17 until
now for them to catch because that guy's
the FBI's like wait we gotta catch him
run that red-handed yeah we have to be
there make sure that there's an actual
exchange happening so they weren't sure
for two years so they had to sit in the
car it's true they do let crimes go on
for a while yeah dude 9/11 bro they had
all those guys on a [ __ ] registry and
they still didn't do yeah that's true
yeah that's true they were all being
watched
nobody gets fired nobody cares that's
the government for young so they're
saying here that he basically spent
twenty thousand a year for ten years he
got [ __ ] comfortable s than I thought
it was gonna be how many thousand a year
for ten years total of two or a hundred
ninety five thousand he was skimming it
that's a lot of money to spend in a
strip club yeah but what was the grant
money though it could have been a
million every year or something yeah I
really
195,000 one years he was fairly fiscally
responsible yeah he was actually so he
was the university's top contractors of
research grant research grants there's
your answer
landing more than ten million dollars in
research money across his whole career
yeah so he was basically skimming it as
a reward but the university's happy
because of how much money he's bringing
into two hundred thousand from ten
million it's not so bad meaning yeah but
what else is he spending no they were
saying that he submitted several
improper charges against his federal
grants for goods and services billed as
at strip clubs he didn't even try to
hide it no that's what they said strip
clubs in the Philadelphia area including
cheerleaders Club risque and attacking
me
he likes the cheerleaders huh spanning
from 20 set 2007 to 2017 and they also
found that he spent money on iTunes and
sports bars iTunes yeah he likes that
music I wonder what his odd his bank was
is what kind of music Bank
I had an expertise see what I had an ex
spent $400 in a day on iTunes on my
credit card that's why you left your
credit card that's why you left her $400
on [ __ ] a bunch of John Mayer many
wait whoa John here's much of that kind
of [ __ ] okay that's not trash the genres
trash to you was the genre for great
whatever that is I hate to do it but I'm
with him on this it's all right I'll
give it to your good person thank you
you have integrity no I didn't do this
for you people say John was it people
have said that John Mayer's oh yes she
loves him that's true
stupid you know I hit the snooze button
I only like John Mayer when he's doing
something not very John Mayer II like
working with Dave Chappelle or singing
with someone who's not just himself
you don't like my but your body is a
wonderland yes you hear it in my head
you get to way too fast after your head
once in your life thank you okay anyway
so this dude here let me show you a
photo yo kids no [ __ ] sorry
oh I wanna play get you white or not why
Oh would you have lost because I named
my only be the new Indian oh that's what
it was
he could be Indian he's interesting is
what he is he is interesting I like how
the back is a blurred zoom of his face
to that that's a [ __ ] smug smile like
he's like dude I've been pulling about
someone that just shows you just never
know who's gonna love strippers yeah I
feel like the captain says [ __ ] I
feel like this was bought as a set
because there's no way anyone could find
a green checkered thing to match that
jacket so perfectly he got that from big
and tall on clearance sold as a set me
more taste I just don't understand he
dresses like Jeff your manager yeah oh
you hear that job hey it's okay okay I
thought I would just go to the brothel
man there are no rules anymore it's 2019
oh yeah we surprised no you go on the
under back page I know about that weird
about it but there's also like that
bunny ranch no no there's like massage
places that you can go to and you have
sex they're Asian owned I know that
actually I think Robert Kraft is also
fairly familiar with that the Patriots
he didn't even know that she's sport she
yeah we did it here bro no you're really
brave well I could make my lips appear
too bro I don't like the strip club I
don't like any of that good for you
talking about you're gonna make me bad
no you know why is because like it's
like you look good
and I like that I like the pole dancing
okay yeah there's so bad right but then
when they come up and say you are
laughing
I might know thank you you were talking
about strip clubs like King of Diamonds
and what was the one in my tootsies like
places like that where spirit right now
Julie
spirit I know where they actually you
know put the dance first like they
actually have good moves I'm talking
about like a strip mall random-ass joint
full of c-section scars yeah where there
is no dancing it's just like hoping
you're a dollar yeah like the main
clients are or like the truckers are
driving across nation really it's sad
very sad I've been to one we were at one
recently and around noon and lunch
specials at strip clubs are unbeatable
really there was this one place in Miami
at the Fuji yes the best turkey club
sandwich I've ever had in my life was
from tutsies in Miami and I used to go
there for lunch when it was half off all
the time uh Elvis impersonator try to
get us to go to one of the lunch buffets
at a strip club because he got
commissioned for anyone that he brought
and these are usually come on check it
off it was at the Las Vegas about you I
could do it almost thank you very much
yeah he was convincing I was like man I
don't know if I could mix that is just
interesting what do you do like you
watch girls do that and you're eating no
but then you you are like completely
eliminated from being judged for not
paying them while they're dancing in
front of you because your hands are
messy you got wing sauce all over them
you're gonna touch the dollar with that
so what do you do you watch them [ __ ]
you watch while you eat spread their
legs and you're eating that's a great
deal
lunch preferably because then they don't
charge cover when you walk in see we
didn't get to experience it cuz we were
there shooting something so we never get
the full experience they were performing
you guys are shooting well no they were
coming in while we were leaving because
we were there all morning and then we
cut it around noon and then they were
coming in for their shift I was like but
he did that's a difference the morning
chef she says the hot ones are on the
weekends at night the d-league is out on
the weekdays the middle ones the
training you know well I mean I'm
wondering when this guy was showing up
they all do you've been a lot of money
tonight but you know what no I
sympathize with that because in 2016
when I first moved to Austin all me and
my friend
my girlfriend's all we did was go to a
strip club every weekend and between
June and August I looked through my
finances as much as it scared me and I
realized I had spent $23,000 at strip
clubs how in hell from June to August oh
my was it from alcohol and like
everything not even I would just take so
much money out of the ATM and handle my
for every single one of my friends
stacks and we would just go crazy
because they would give us the alcohol
for free like we wouldn't we never had
to pay for that they it was a very great
deal until I looked at my finances what
inspired such generosity it was the
first time in my life where I started
making money and I was truly 100%
independent not dating anyone not doing
anything and my friends are all enablers
nobody was like yeah and then the strip
club started sending us a party bus from
anywhere we were in Austin to bring us
there and then it would take us all home
one by one oh how nice it's like an uber
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]